[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host this is a show
where we talk about your work we talk
about your relationships we talk about
your money and we talk about you right
in front of you it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it triple eight
eight two five five
two two five one of the things we do
around ramsey is a brand called entree
leadership where we talk with small
businesses and business leaders
around the globe but particularly in the
united states about how to run a
business properly and how we've grown
our business from a card table in my
living room
to a to a major national brand how do we
do this what are the steps what have we
done how do we run a business and in the
process of doing that one of my favorite
leadership writers and speakers has
become one of my best friends he's just
a great guy pat lincione is with us has
written many many many best-selling
books and uh hanging out with us for a
a well all day just about we've had you
on every show in here you're kind of
popular when you come in the building
it's a party it's a party baby pat
speaks at entree leadership summit this
coming may among many others jay leno
will be there me and i'm trying to think
of all the other people deloney of
course will be speaking and coleman i'll
be speaking and i'll have to think of
all the rest of them but it's going to
be a lineup it'll be another party about
3 000 folks will be there and we are
really really excited about that oh
jocko's coming back this year yeah yeah
that'll be good and i found the list
here uh will garrido oh man will is
incredible have you ever met will i have
not oh you're gonna love him and dr
henry cloud will be back our friend as
well jenny kern kern lima and jay as i
said jay leno jade simmons jade is uh
an excellent speaker so you look forward
to seeing her it's a great lineup uh the
entree leadership summit orlando florida
in may make sure you make plans to
attend but pat's hanging out with us
today welcome back it's great to be here
it's so much fun we appreciate you the
book that we have adopted around here
many of them uh
the uh just five dysfunctions of a team
is going around this place all the time
apparently there's a lot of dysfunction
here we need to do it over and over
again but we do it all the time we do
conflict well
the the advantage has gone around here
and certainly ideal team player has
become the handbook of our recruiting
and they're are deciding if we're going
to keep people in hr and that kind of a
thing the hungry humble smart model is
just
lights out and the new stuff that you're
working on is
oh it's shall we say genius the working
genius yeah it's really good
i appreciate that it came about by
accident i've never worked on anything
that i've been more excited about than
this so the model is called the six
types of working genius and david i was
here about a little over a year ago when
we launched this
almost a quarter of a million people
have taken it
the stories we're getting that was one
of the first ones to tell you yeah you
get to me and you tested you on it yeah
and you hit oh it's accurate because
there is no genius
[Laughter]
you didn't break the model i didn't
break the model it ferreted me out but
yeah it's uh it the these things no the
book is out no the book is not out
there's a shortage of trees
um oh shortage of paper i should say not
trees but so it's they're going to be
it's going to take longer to print this
darn thing if you believe that but
so it's going to be out this late spring
early summer yeah we started buying
trees in august to put out a book
yesterday so every everyday millionaire
babies millionaires came out yesterday
and yeah we were we were fighting tree
shortages all the way back in the summer
it's not crazy ready for this show
paper costs too through the roof right
yeah all that aside working genius book
is underway and the assessment is
available today let's talk about what
this thing measures these six types of
working genius so so there are six
activities dave that are required in any
kind of work
and and the corresponding there are six
geniuses that people have god-given
talents that give them joy and energy
but we only have two
of the six so we need all six to whether
we're running a radio show or running a
company
planning a family vacation running a
home a marriage anything else we need
all six but every individual just has
two and the two areas of genius are
where you get joy and energy and you
tend to do better you're more successful
you make more money and you come home
from work a lot happier it's like you're
a natural you're a natural and god lets
everybody be a natural but if you don't
know what you're a natural at
and your job description is for your two
weakest ones you're screwed there's a
lot of people listening to this show
dave that are miserable at work and it's
because they don't realize that they're
doing exactly what god didn't intend
them to do
intending for them to not do
so this assessment that takes 10 minutes
to complete
and and you get the result the stories
we've gotten dave a woman called us and
said she was about to sell her business
she was in the staffing business she
took the assessment
that very day she was like oh my gosh
i'm doing the wrong things as ceo
i need to do the things i'm best at
reorganize my team to do the things i'm
not best at
she decided
she was going to completely reorganize
she's happier they're more successful
than they've ever been she didn't sell
it she did not sell it because it was
just a matter of the wrong skill set we
had another guy who was about to go to a
performance review and he knew it wasn't
going to be pretty because he and he did
the assessment and he looked at the
results and takes 10 minutes and he
looked at the result and said well crap
i'm in the wrong job he went to his
managers and said this says that this is
what i'm good at is there any way i
could use these things they said we have
another job over here that would be
perfect the guy got a raise
because he actually had vocabulary for
saying this is what i'm great at and
they said we need that instead of
getting smackdown what are the six
geniuses the first one is the genius of
wonder which is the people that have
their head in the clouds
they ask questions like why is the world
the way it is is there a better way to
do this i wonder what our customers
really think they ponder things
it's at 50 000 feet it's really
important but a lot of times people
don't value that i was working with a
high-tech company who was behind the
market in their products they did the
assessment
none of their executives had wonder
in fact most of them had it as their
lowest area
their frustration and they said this is
why we're behind no wonder you're behind
the market yeah and they and the cfo
said we better hire a wanderer or get
more people in here to help us wonder
the next one is invention this is
something i like and that is these are
people that love to they're just built
to come up with new ideas
they do it even when it's not called for
and so they they like a clean slate they
like doing things from scratch
and they just love to invent the next
one is discernment this is one of yours
this is your chief area and that's why
you i watch you when you're taking calls
discernment is when you can just
get information and you just parse it in
a way that uses instinct and intuition
and and and
and variable thinking to come up with
ideas and solutions and you evaluate
things very quickly
it's not magic it's just the way god
wired you so discernment is really
important
once you discern an idea then somebody
has to galvanize it and that's the
person who just loves to sell they love
to get up in front of people and say
let's go let's do this this is going to
be charged yep
and and i can do that but it's not one
of my areas of genius and when i have to
do it too much i get burned out yeah
that's what brought this whole model
about i was burned out in my own company
and people said what's going on with you
and i said i don't know and that's how
we figured this out so wonder invention
discernment
galvanizing the next one is called
enablement
and this enablement in a good way these
are the kind of people that you go to
them they're fabulous on a team and you
say we need help and they're like got it
i know exactly what you need i'm gonna
make that happen
the last one is called tenacity and that
is people who just love to finish stuff
that's yours that's your other genius
they're like no bs can we just push this
across the finish line get it done get
her done
get her done check it out
lynch only with me this half hour we're
gonna come back take some calls for him
workinggenius.com if you want to take
the assessment into the promo code
ramsey you get 25 off it's usually 25
that'll make it 18.75
oh come on you spent that just thinking
about this
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show
at lincione my guest this half hour one
of our favorite leadership
speakers and teachers around the world
we've learned so much from him he
teaches at entree leadership summit
almost every year and will be this
coming may as well if you don't have
your tickets yet there's quite a lineup
probably one of the top leadership
events of the year coming up in orlando
in may i think maybe sold out i may need
to quit pushing it but um find out
before i run my mouth here but we were
just talking about his new assessment
it's not that new about a year old with
a book coming out soon as we get some
trees
called the genius your working genius go
to workinggenius.com enter the promo
code ramsey for 25 off the assessment
normally 25
it's 18.75 these segments go so fast
with a discount if you put in the ramsey
promo code it's knox 25 okay so
these segments go so fast i want to make
sure we emphasize the importance that
this is not merely for work it's not
merely for someone squaring the middle
of their career or merely for a
corporate leader it's for
uh just about anybody that's uh getting
close to wearing adult clothes yeah you
know we had a pastor call us and say
he thought
he he felt terrible about his job about
being a pastor he thought maybe he
shouldn't have been one because he
wasn't good at sermons
and he didn't understand that he felt
terribly guilty looked at and he said
oh my gosh i don't have wonder or
invention that's where a lot of these
sermons come from but i have these other
things oh i don't have to feel bad about
this anymore i'm going to get people to
help me with this and he said 15 years
he felt bad about it maybe he shouldn't
have been in that job
my favorite story is a guy who called
and said hey pat i thought my wife
didn't like me and i we laughed and he
goes i mean i really thought that she
she was kind of down on me all the time
because i'm an inventor
so he'd come home and he said honey i
have a great idea for our family or
whatever else she was a discerner
so she would say out of love
well here's why that might not work
and she's a dream killer right and
they literally took this on their
anniversary he said and he said
suddenly she goes that's i'm loving you
when i do that and he was like oh my
gosh she doesn't she's not she's not
against me she's trying to help me
but
but i just think i don't know how
anybody if you're a high school student
or a college student or if you're
retiring
figure out what your geniuses are
because that's where you're going to get
joy and energy and you talk about
financial peace
having that piece of knowing you're
doing what god intends you to do is so
powerful big deal it's a big deal
working genius.com go take the
assessment you'll be glad you did we're
kind of big on assessments around here
we've got a bunch of them floating
around the building we've done a few
we've recommended a bunch from other
people as well uh our friend let's pair
it there's a simba's assessment for uh
people getting ready to get married is
absolutely holy
um i i i don't uh you know you know none
of us that have assessments or create
them or have these ideas around them
believe that you know that it's
anything's come absolute but what it
does is it gives you a tendency it gives
you a lane to run in
and uh you can swerve a little in that
lane if you want to absolutely but you
just when you take one of these things
and you have a little better
understanding of who you are
then it it always leads you to more
success
yeah you know at the end of the day dave
what this does this is all about work
too it's very specific to work so it's
not just your personality that's like
getting things done
but what happens in the workplace is
that we do two things that we shouldn't
do we judge others
in unfairly
and we judge ourselves and feel guilty
and
so sometimes you look at somebody and
you say gosh she's lazy or that guy's
not very smart and then you look at her
working genius and go oh she has no
tenacity
it's just that she that's not laziness
she's still got a work ethic but she's
not a finisher or that guy's really
bright when it comes to implementing but
he's not an inventor no and so when we
judge other people and even attribute it
to their virtues or lack of virtue
that's a really bad thing it's so much
better to go oh that's just how god
wired you now that doesn't mean we still
don't have to do things and you still
have to judge the virtues i mean because
you have to but you got to parse those
out yeah but if you if you have a job
that is causing that needs completion to
be part of the job like a project
manager you know you need to draw you
need to drawstring this thing and get
her done
and then you got someone that can't seem
to do that and it's this stuff then they
get accused of the saying around here
will end up being oh he can catch him
but he can't clean them right you know
that kind of stuff we need catchers and
cleaners yeah exactly exactly carol is
with us in alexandria louisiana carol
your question for pat lincione
yeah thank you both for having me on
today pat just for that we are beginning
to use working genius at our company oh
so my question's in a little different
direction today we are loving working
genius
we use a lot of your resources on
engagement uh team performance advantage
all of that work and we've also been
looking at research from marcus
buckingham on engagement and resiliency
so in uh that research you know he talks
about it being
the frequency of one-on-one meetings and
check-ins not necessarily the medium
like person uh in person versus virtual
or the depth of the content i was
looking at how that relates when we look
at the three factors of job misery
specifically irrelevance and anonymity
how are you seeing that uh in the work
that you're doing in terms of that
frequency versus the depth of the
content that gum she knows your content
better than you do i know people come up
i love that character in your book and
i'm like
yeah tell me more about that character
because i don't i don't remember when i
wrote that
well carol um first of all marcus
buckingham and dave and i sat down at
entre leadership last year and talked
about this that was a great meal it was
and um
so i think what what he talks about i
think is really important the frequency
of communication is critical
and and and the medium is not as
important i mean i've seen people build
strong relationships over zoom i prefer
it to be in person don't get me wrong it
should be is when you can
but and then there's people that work
right next to each other and don't
develop relationships and don't have
good talks so i would say they go very
much together and i think you hit the
nail on the head anonymity if you're not
having regular communication with
somebody you don't they're not going to
feel known and irrelevance if you're not
spending time with them and talking
about the work they're doing
then they're not going to feel like it
matters so i think you hit the nail on
the head that that's where marcus's
stuff and my stuff come together
on um on the engagement and what she's
talking about is a book dave that i
wrote years ago called the three signs
of a miserable job and i had to change
the name because nobody could take it to
work
[Laughter]
so it's now called the truth about
employee engagement published a book
here called quitter one time nobody
could take that to work right so so i i
love carol that you made that connection
because when it comes to employee
engagement what i say is if if your
manager knows you if they remind you why
your job matters and you know and you
have a way to measure if you're doing a
good job you're to love your work
and regular communication with your
manager is critical to that that sounds
so obvious but just it's just the tag
teaming the handoff of the baton with
that regular frequency that that ensures
that you're touching all three of those
jobs job misery basis exactly if there's
not regular communication you're not
going to be able to do that okay you
can't ensure that that's occurring
if you meet once a year then you know
for a review you're not getting you
don't know if those three things are
happening or not right and it doesn't it
shouldn't every interaction shouldn't be
formal like i'm sitting down with you
it's like you're talking in between
things i have to put them on the
calendar
well my calendar's full yeah you got to
so my to do one-on-ones i got to book
them
for my immediate team i'm i'm around
them a lot but for other things i do too
but it to be you're busy i know i've
seen well every time i'm around somebody
usually work otherwise it's on a project
of some kind right working on something
we're putting and we're doing an event
tomorrow night we're launching a book
we've got pat lancioni coming to town
whatever it is you know so i'm in a
group setting that's not conducive to
one-on-ones usually if you rely on it
being just haphazard it's not gonna
happen i have to i have to ding ding
ding i gotta ring the bell it doesn't
work uh brent is with us in madison
wisconsin brent your question for pat
good afternoon guys thank you for taking
my call huge fan of the work you both do
thank you
my question today is really around the
ideal team player so a little background
my corner of the business is about 88
total employees both direct and indirect
uh reports about 15 months ago i led my
direct report leadership team through
learning and implementing the ideal team
player practices in our hiring process
after a 12-month hiring cycle we're
feeling great about the candidates that
we've brought on as team members
uh with that when a new hire starts
they're gifted that book as part of
their welcome basket to get on board
with the concepts
our highly engaged team members before
we run out of time quick question
sure my question is we've got folks on
the high highly engaged in and that are
on board with them and
new hires and those that we're coaching
but i got to get the ones in the middle
on board and understanding the concepts
and within working geniuses
galvanizing is not our strength
okay got it
here's the thing sit down with those
people in a room and just say everybody
rate rank yourself first second or third
on humble hungry and smart everybody's
gotta got an order you have to force
rank them yeah and then just do a little
group teaching yeah and work you don't
have to be a good teacher or galvanizer
and have everybody put the concept out
there it'll germinate itself and people
will say this is my third and let's all
talk about that yeah it makes a big
difference you can pull off their
answers into a one-on-one if you need to
if you've got a problem absolutely
that's good stuff pat lincione thanks
for hanging out brother great to see you
dave good to see you man
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
wow what a week we are having at ramsey
it is launch week for the new book baby
steps millionaires it is selling
at a blindingly wonderful rate thank you
people
we are so thankful for all of you you
are amazing
i uh i hesitate to say how many books
we've sold it's um
it's nice it's wonderful it's
thank you thank you thank you thank you
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today and a little preview are
we supposed to preview this we could
preview it i'm fine with that into the
future
a couple of hours george will be doing
with his wife his debt-free scream he's
paid off his house whoa
whoa
there we go i'm sure everyone listening
did a woo too i'll be doing that too
i'll be doing it i can't wait it's a
signature woo so there you go and
speaking of signature who's on the stage
right here in ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage brooks and paige are
going to kick off the debt free thing
welcome guys good to have you thanks
good to be here good to be here how much
of you guys paid off uh 162
645 dollars way to go and how long did
this take two and a half years way to go
and your range of income during that
time uh first year was about 55 and last
year it went up to about 180. wow nice
jump
very cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a registered nurse oh there it is
i'm a tv photojournalist okay well
neither one of you have had anything to
do in the last two years definitely not
very bored oh my god wow way to go where
do you all live uh milwaukee wisconsin
okay cool well way to go you guys
what kind of debt was this 163 thousand
oh lord a little bit everything we were
certainly normal um we had uh credit
cards student loans cars
you name it yeah little medical dad
y'all were just like pitiful normal yeah
yes yeah disgusting
what was the big one here
student loans
all together our student loans topped in
just over a hundred thousand i think so
most of it was that was that nursing
school uh no i have a degree before
nursing school so i was paying for the
degree i didn't even use ouch
oh there's that one okay very cool very
cool so how long you guys been married
uh three years in december okay so right
after you come home from the honeymoon
it sounds like we went made a list of
the deaths and had an oh my god moment
or something what happened tell me the
story so uh i saw a high school
classmate post about some success of
paying off that using your your uh
program and uh
leading up to the wedding i was having a
lot of unsettling feelings because i
just felt like we were drowning in that
and we financed the entire wedding all
22 000 of that why not yeah yeah
absolutely yeah um then we got back and
we were just
it just felt like we were drowning and
we needed to do something and
um i mentioned something to her about is
like hey i saw this high school
classmate that posted this on facebook
and we checked it out um
kind of watched a couple of videos wound
up ordering your book uh read the book
and then uh enrolled in an fpu class wow
wow look at you that's awesome
okay so i'm gonna guess and say uh
brooks is the saver
no absolutely he's the spender
absolutely he's the one that was feeling
the weight of this yeah he went all in
he was all like oh i'm stressed out i'm
freaked out i didn't think usually
spenders are like whoa i'm in congress
who cares yeah i'm much i'm the more
emotional of us too so i think that
maybe had something to do with it okay
i was doing all the budgeting and i was
scared but you know he was just the free
spirit and i'm like yeah it'll be fine
you know one day we'll make more money
and it'll be fine and i think when he
approached me it was like okay like
we're on the same page like we know we
can't sustain this and we need to do
something about it so so it's game on
where you read the book and you went
okay i'm going to turn this up a little
hotter we're going to go on through
financial peace university i mean i
think within six weeks of getting
married we were starting our first
budget and paying off debt and enrolled
in fpu class we just yeah we just took
it right
right
you kind of had this guilt about all of
your free spiritness you were doing all
the spending and you felt the weight of
this and you're like we got to do
something we can't keep living like this
yeah and it's kind of um i've actually
seen a few friends and tried to warn
them about this as we were like kind of
the first of our friends to get married
and it felt like when we were engaged
everyone was kind of gallivanting us
around and like gloating with us and
like we were going out and spending
money putting it on credit cards going
out to eat spending stuff we didn't need
to be spending and then the reality set
in after we got married that we can't
live like this anymore yeah wow
very cool i like that that's true i had
no thought about that you have to go on
the after engagement tour yes yeah
parading you around spending all of the
money that you don't have pretty much
yeah look at this look at this look here
look at this look at this look at this
yeah it's everywhere yeah that's great i
like that that's that does happen so
what were some of those sacrifices that
you guys made and when you were crushing
it you were throwing 60 70 000 a year
you went nuts here we we worked i mean
the nature of our jobs i mean we work
nights holidays weekends this was the
first year we actually spent a holiday
not at work um we were i mean the
pandemic actually really helped us
because there wasn't anything to do so
we went to work i mean we would have
done it anyway but it was nice knowing
that
you know we weren't missing anything did
you miss some netflix series i mean
there was a lot going on there you know
we didn't catch tiger king but i think
we're okay for it
[Laughter]
i think you're just fine
i watched it you're just fine yeah yeah
it was it was easy for her to pick up
hours and stuff at the hospital yeah if
you say if you said if they if they came
in and said uh who wants to work extra
you're like pick me pretty much yeah
when i stopped um they were like why
aren't you working so much anymore i'm
like i don't have to
you know and it was just they got used
to seeing me there like 70 hours a week
and they're like where are you and for
me i wasn't uh i can't like pick up
hours as much at the tv station so i
wound up driving a forklift on the side
oh wow yeah we pieced jobs together i
think 2020 we filed taxes on like eight
or nine different w-2s we did everything
you name it we yeah we made some pretty
big sacrifices but we wouldn't change it
at all who were your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you well
these three people sitting right here um
my parents are watching virtually and uh
my dad couldn't be here today because
had too much work to do but um yeah our
parents and our siblings and a couple of
friends as well yeah some like
co-workers especially as we got close
they
you know we've inspired um quite a few
people to at least look at their
finances which that's a start so that's
what happened with you yeah some guy
posted his story and you went i want
that exactly yeah and so who are the
three people with you
uh this is my mom uh my brother and my
sister-in-law awesome very cool okay
good gotta know who the posse is here
all right good deal way to go you guys
yeah wait how does it feel to be free it
feels unbelievable yeah if we can so we
just took um a big celebration trip to
ireland and
in december that's incredible we
actually got quarantined uh at the end
we couldn't come home i got covered and
we couldn't fly back home and just
knowing that we had like we weren't even
worried about money we're like this
sucks we had to stay an extra eight days
and had to use our emergency fund to pay
for the uh the extra days there but it
was okay because we had the money
extended stay in ireland ah like the
worst things could happen yeah i mean we
were stuck in a room we couldn't leave
the hotel room
okay they slide food on your shoulder
and there's a part where you're sick
yeah but yeah they literally slid food
under the door yeah it was uh it was
quite but you know it was the first
vacation we'd taken and it was like we
only have to worry about money like this
is not what we planned but i am stuck in
a room but i'm not driving a forklift
yeah good guys way to go i'm so proud of
y'all thank you well done okay now
you've been through the financial peace
university class somebody's getting
ready to start right now it's listening
at this moment
what do you say the key is to getting
out of debt you were so successful
i think it's relentless determination um
there's gonna be times where you
want to give up um it's it's having that
gazelle intensity i mean like to the
point where she and i both actually have
tattoos of gazelles um that we got after
uh we got debt-free that's that's how
much the gazelle intensity meant to us
because that's
that was the key there were so many
times willing to give up there's so many
times being in our 20s and seeing our
friends around us
go out and do all this stuff and travel
and we had to be so disciplined and
intense about it and it paid off was it
worth it absolutely yeah proud of you
again way to go well we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires it's ironic that
this is the week the book comes out and
it's the next chapter for your story
that's where you're headed we'll also
give you an extra copy of total money
makeover for you to give away so you can
disrupt somebody's life and you never
know they might use it as a coaster but
it might they might actually read it so
sometimes that happens too so good stuff
you guys we're very proud of you well
done brooks and page milwaukee wisconsin
163 000 paid off in two and a half years
making 55 to 180. what's the secret
intensity and a lot of hard work well
done guys count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
wow
never gets old
there it is
yeah game on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it's here tomorrow
night thursday night january the 13th is
the
building wealth for 2022 event rachel
cruz george campbell my co-host today
and i will be talking to you about how
to build wealth in this year in this
current environment what's working
what's not how why the proven plan not
this discussion of
glitz and glitter and confetti cannons
but what's real
how do you really
build wealth we're going to talk about
tomorrow night we've got about 1700 1800
people or whatever scheduled in the sold
out event in person
sold out very very quickly and guess
what we've got a little over a hundred
thousand approach 130 000 people going
to watch online a live stream and it's
free to watch online if you want to
watch on the live stream 7 00 p.m
central time thursday night january the
13th
how do you watch for free you just go to
ramseysolutions.com right now
slash wealth ramsey solutions.com wealth
and you can register for free for the
live stream we'll send it to you you'll
be able to watch it you're going to
learn all about
all the stuff that's happening out there
and we got a a logical sound discussion
about the whole process and i'm looking
forward to george and
rachel and i being able to talk to you
guys for a couple hours tomorrow night
it's gonna be a lot of fun and it is uh
timely i've been doing interviews george
all week for the book release and uh
some of the things we're going to be
talking about come up almost in every
country very naturally this is all the
trending stuff i get messages every
single day and people are wondering what
to do they're worried there's some fomo
there's crypto over here what about real
estate what do i invest in what what's
an annuity there's all these questions
and i love how simple you make it and
logic and common sense it's wild how
much it's countercultural these days
it's so rare it's having a superpower
but yeah yeah i was on fox business uh
monday morning yeah the first thing on
there they start talking about the dive
the crypto crypto's taking a big dime
yeah it's crashing it's been it's been
had a bad week and uh
um you know that's certainly not
necessarily incumbent about what the
crypto's entire future is but it's just
they want to talk about it because you
know
whatever whatever bleeds it leads right
and so
um you know we get to have a crypto
conversation in the middle of the baby
steps millionaire book but that's okay
it's okay because hey what works and
what doesn't the baby's test millionaire
book is about what is the
fastest
right way
to build wealth
the fastest shortest distance
right way by right way i mean has the
highest probability of actually
occurring
and that's important yeah because i mean
there's a lot of ways you could get rich
but now 10 years later
when when all the confetti has
settled who really won
where did it how did it really work out
for you you know and
guess what there's some data on that
yeah a lot and i've been listening to
the audiobook of baby steps millionaires
really enjoying that and you talk about
there's there's a right way but there's
also a lot of wrong ways that can
distract you along this journey and so
that's just as important avoiding those
traps and focusing on what works
deborah's in erie pennsylvania hi
deborah welcome to the ramsay show
hello
hi how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
i was wondering if you could give me
some ideas and how to interview for a
financial advisor
i've had a couple of bad experiences
and i just don't know where to progress
from here if there's certain talk points
that i should be looking for or asking
about what was the bad experience what
happened
well
i had i had a financial advice where i
had my 401 my roth 401 was
and
they think they've been good for like 12
years well they just switched brokers
like six months ago
and since they switched brokers
i'm losing like a thousand dollars a
month
so i need to move that somewhere because
i no longer why were you losing a
thousand dollars a month
good question i called and left several
messages they'll get back to me no phone
call okay i think i found the problem
okay yeah
um
[Laughter]
there's a slap in the face now i'm
messing with you a little bit but uh
here's the thing i figured out
most of the time when i interview people
and i ask that question it comes back to
something like you said
and here's what i want you to shift what
you want
from a financial advisor not to dumb it
down
but i want to change the responsibility
okay number one you should never invest
in something you don't understand
so the next time that you lose a
thousand dollars a month and i ask you
why you can tell me
rather than my advisor didn't do his job
no that's your job you need to
understand what's going on with the
investment the advisor's job is to
advise your job is to own the money
that makes sense
well
yes i i get reports but it doesn't
really list what i'm in and you don't
know what the flip is going on group
numbers
yeah i don't know what's going on so
your financial advisor is a failure and
didn't need to be fired but not because
he lost a thousand dollars a month but
because he never bothered to let you
know
ongoing
why your investments are doing what
they're doing and what they are so you
know and you can say oh i'm losing a
thousand dollars a month and i really
don't care because i think it's a
temporary thing because i understand
this or i'm losing a thousand dollars a
month because i'm in the wrong stupid
stuff and i need to move it because i
understand it so the second thing is
after you say i'm never investing in
anything again i don't understand and i
don't keep up with the second thing is i
never hire another financial advisor
that has the heart of a salesman
again you hire one that has the heart of
a teacher
because you don't need to be sold their
services you need to be sold you need to
be taught what's going on in your life
this is your freaking money and here's
the irony you probably have more money
than he does
could be yeah
and so you probably you know at the at
the core you probably actually might
know as much as he knows on a lot of
things except nuances so i teach america
how to handle their money and i have
a financial advisor
but i don't use them to manage my money
i use them to teach me what's going on
and then i make the decisions with them
on how i'm going to manage my money i
never say my financial advisor manages
my money i manage my money with their
advice
if you see the difference
you feel the difference on your
shoulders you just put i just put the
weight on your shoulders
well right it's it's having someone show
me how to
cipher through
all these codes
put
and
checks
put it into one of those
don't put it into one of those codes
unless you know what the flip it is
right well that was another thing the
investor that i spoke to through my
local bank where i have like half of my
money at i went to him and i said hey i
got this money i want to invest
could you give me
like maybe 10 mutual funds that have
that that are paying over
10 percent a year
and
and and let me choose one
what he said
stand he said
he
he gave me a list of other things that
weren't even mutual funds yeah because
he's a he's because he works for a bank
you know you don't go to the muffler
shop for your transmission either that's
rule number three
so so here's what i'm going to tell you
i want you to go that was the second one
yeah i want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com
and click on smart investor
that's a group of
financial advisors that don't work for
me but that have agreed to do things the
way i teach
and mainly with the heart of a teacher
and um
and i you got gravel in your voice you
got grit i like you a lot
and i want you to use that and say okay
this is my freaking money it's you
people are gonna do what i say
and you're going to teach me about this
or i'm not going to use you i'm going to
fire your butt
and that's how you need to treat this
anytime you get anyone in the financial
world who's telling you what to do
instead of teaching you
run and fire them yeah and you need to
be interviewing them asking questions
like how how much access will i have to
you how much can i communicate with you
how often will you communicate back
what's your experience like what clients
do you work with ask good questions and
the smart investor pros will not steer
you wrong yeah and if you don't like one
of them don't use them you know if you
don't like my advice don't use it but
know what the flip you're doing
and take your personal responsibility
for the management of your money with
other people helping you
and teaching you it's my responsibility
to put together my estate plan my estate
planning attorney
shows me some good ways to do it and i
decide
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice this is
the show where we talk about your
relationships your work your money and
you
george camel ramsey personality and host
of the fine print another ramsey
networks production
podcast you need to check out just
finished up its first season is my
co-host open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
this is book launch week the new book
baby steps millionaires is out it is
selling uh at an unbelievably wonderful
pace thank you america wow
crazy i appreciate it very much and of
course it is how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
you can get the book anywhere great
books are sold including
ramseysolutions.com kayla starts off
this hour in boston hi kayla welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure how can george and i help
so i'm just having trouble with my
monthly budget
i've been budgeting for a while but me
and my husband seem to
not be on the same page with this one
little thing and it's when you're
so say
your first paycheck doesn't come until
the middle uh like six days into january
would you still put
the items you're buying like groceries
and stuff into december or would you put
that into january even if you haven't
been paid in january yet
so you're saying you have a line item in
your budget and the funds won't be there
in time
no so we have money that we haven't put
into our savings account yet we have
leftover money
and money that we budgeted for
but
so my husband's saying when
um i buy groceries on january 2nd say
then that should be in the january
budget
even though
um we haven't started the gender like we
haven't gotten paid in january yet
does that make sense yeah well that's
okay i mean you can use the money that
on your december 31st paycheck and
that's going to fund part of january
right
right so we're just getting confused
because we're both doing different
things so i don't know if there's a
better way to you can't both do
different things right that right there
tells me there's a bunch of breakdown
you don't have two budgets you have one
right and we have the same every dollar
account so
when we're putting things in it's just
getting messed up and i just wanted your
help to get us on the same page because
we both love you so yeah
we appreciate that so um yeah
number one whatever we do we both have
to be doing it both of you doing two
different game plans is going to screw
up the math as you probably already
discovered that's going to cause a
bigger fight than actually
yeah that's going to be a bigger fight
than anything else you do so but the uh
so so the way we did it is um
it's okay to set up january's budget and
have some leftover money from december
to fund until the first check comes in
january but january if you buy food on
january 2nd that should show up in
january's budget
it should show up on the second that you
bought food now where did the money come
from well there's money in your food
envelope left over because you knew you
weren't going to get a check when you
did your december budget and so you had
money to fund into the first week of
january does that make sense
yeah yeah it does that's what my husband
was saying but i i was over complicating
this i think
so
in your case if you said
uh
i mean the problem is is that everything
is set up on a monthly basis
if you were just running it week by week
uh or are running it not counting the
first of the month
uh because you're not getting paid first
and 15th uh that wouldn't be unusual but
but the the
every dollar software doesn't run that
way and it makes it really hard to keep
up with
it really runs on the calendar right
right right yeah and that's what we
usually use every dollar yeah so you
said that so that's good thank you and
it's good it's good software it does
it's very robust it does the job but
yeah you've got to figure out a way to
cover it kind of like um
if you got paid at the first of the
month
but your cable bill comes
towards the middle before the second
check comes
then you wait to pay the cable bill
until out of the second check you don't
pay it out of the first check because
it's right up there on it
right makes sense
yes it does thank you okay hey that's a
really good question here's what's
really important about it the details of
the answer don't matter what matters is
two things one is you're actually
freaking using a budget
that is huge that's huge
and the second thing is that you are
engaging
you're engaging in your in your
relationship
and you're doing it with your husband
otherwise the fact if you had not had
this conflict because you either weren't
doing a budget or you weren't doing it
together and bumping into each other
that would be a bigger danger sign than
the nuances of this answer it's almost
semantics and the fact that you guys are
on the same page both doing one budget
together willing to do it that's huge
but uh dave we run into this
occasionally and it comes down to having
a little buffer you know we're not
saying with zero based budget doesn't
mean you have zero dollars in your bank
account that's a good point too and so
having a little buffer in there can
really help some people like to get a
month ahead if that's something that you
can do and that gives you some some
peace to say hey we've got you know two
thousand dollars in a checking account
this is if you're later on the baby
steps but that can sometimes help
couples get over the the idea of we're
going to run out of money mid money yeah
what you do need to set is some kind of
a buffer and just make that your
baseline we don't go below that
in the checking account uh except in
dire situations but i mean at least keep
like a hundred dollars in there you do
not want to run the checking account on
zero balance
because you're gonna be running down to
zero all the time you're gonna bump into
stuff that's not that's not good so you
need to keep some kind of a buffer in
there and that's your baseline and you
never go below that you treat that like
that's zero
you know if it's a hundred bucks or
fifty bucks or a thousand bucks whatever
it is we used to in the old days that's
a thousand years ago we keep a thousand
in there at least
because that got free checking if you
left a thousand bucks in there i don't
even know what it does now i don't keep
up with it that close in terms of what's
free i've got so many bank accounts and
so many things here now but uh
but and we keep a lot more than a
thousand in checking these days but the
the the point being that we that was our
baseline that was the the floor yeah so
to speak we wouldn't get down below that
very very good question that's very
important thank you for joining us emily
is in portland maine emily i'm not going
to get to you i looked up and saw the
clock i'm going to bring you back up a
little while so george what we've
learned this budget thing and this every
dollar thing is really important because
we've learned in
uh almost ten thousand people over six
seven thousand families going through
financial peace university the highest
correlating behavior with success
meaning if you said
dave tell me one behavior that's going
to cause me to become successful doing
the things in financial peace university
meaning getting out of debt
being generous becoming wealthy the
number one thing that we see and there's
not even a close second is couples doing
a zero-based budget the way we teach
together
using every dollar yeah the ones that do
that
their their results are head and
shoulders above everybody else
they're like well i'm going to take the
class and i'm going to issue this and
ish that we don't really do a budget and
then you wonder why i kind of got it in
my head
or i do a budget but it's not a zero
based
or i'm not using the every dollar app
because i don't like that
you know
your results are like one-tenth of the
people that actually do that one thing
properly so her question is really vital
yeah great question on paper on purpose
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
jesse
and katie are with us from fort worth
texas it says on my screen you guys are
debt-free congratulations
thank you hi dave thank you so much sure
thank you well done how much debt have
you paid off
we paid off sixty thousand dollars cool
how long did that take
it took about two and a half years way
to go and your range of income during
that time
oh we went from about 50 000 to 105.
good what do you guys do for a living
um i am a senior copywriter for an
agency here um in plano and i'm a
freelance writer and i i watch our child
as well way to go very cool what kind of
debt was this 60 000
well we had a little bit of everything
we had
a handful of credit cards medical bills
taxes from our freelance business
we had a car payment and some student
loans wow everything you were normal
yeah
yes
what woke you up what happened two and a
half years ago
well our you know the birth of our son
uh kind of made us just uh evaluate
things uh now how bad things had gotten
and uh we got uh we talked about it and
once we got plugged into an fdu class uh
with our church uh we really uh started
to make some changes yes sir
wow okay so nothing like having a baby
to uh cause you to go uh oh this just
got real
right that was exactly it yes yeah way
to go guys fun so it all happens with
fpu
yes um we you know we had been living in
colorado dave and we moved back to texas
to kind of start trying to get a grip on
our finances
my parents really generously let us
move in with them um just so we could
uh you know just kind of
start getting things together a little
bit and i had
um i had your name in the in the back of
my head and when i when i knew that you
know we needed to start moving forward i
found a copy of the total money makeover
um
and then we you know jess and i i showed
it to him and we started kind of getting
those glimmers of hope and we we knew
the next steps needed to be going to fpu
so we found um fpu at a church that was
real close to my parents and that church
is actually it's been our
home church um now for years and so fpu
really led us to that and it's just i
can't tell you what a blessing that in
itself has been but yes fpu really um
got it started for us i love it so what
were those steps you guys took along the
way and what was that kind of turning
point where you went oh my gosh i think
this is working
sure um you know getting on every dollar
was definitely key
and once we started to do the budget and
actually see and just what we had coming
in where it was going and talking about
it together that was having our monthly
budget meetings that was certainly key
and but i think for for myself the
really big thing that happened was just
a paradigm shift when it came to debt i
just had to um
i had to really change my thinking when
it came to when it came to debt and
accept that it really was
you know except that
you know the borrower is slave to the
lender and that that's what helped kick
start it for me
wow so the mindset turned into behavior
change
right yeah it was it was definitely uh
just that i i always say it is i
remember
hearing dave say uh at some point uh you
know a budget
is telling your money where it's gonna
go instead of you know
your money just flowing away from you uh
to people who
who don't manage it flowing away from
people who don't manage it well and uh
staying with people who do
and
that was it was just really
identifying the various forms of debt uh
because they don't always call it debt
you know maybe overdraft protection or
payment plans or whatever but yeah they
have a lot of way of disguising it it's
still debt you're right right right
that's good insight so so what's the
name of the church that drew you guys in
it's first baptist wiley oh very good
and we would we would love to just give
a shout out to the um the teachers of
our class uh mike and rhonda logsdon and
they took us a refu they still teach fpu
at our church and they are just really
incredible we still get emails from them
like monthly encouraging all of the
students who've gone through their class
and they're just really incredible
sounds like super coordinators and
they're ending up recruiting people for
the church too that's wonderful yeah yes
absolutely yeah very good good job guys
the good job proud of you guys well done
who is your biggest cheerleader is the
lot that you're your coordinator for
sure who else
yes absolutely i'm our coordinator i
really we owe a lot to my to my parents
they they definitely um
supported us uh you know in this journey
along the way and and we also want to
give one other shout out to um alex and
sheryl klager who were went through fpu
with us and they actually came out to
nashville not too long ago and they did
a debt-free scream and the ramsey
parking lot which was really special for
them so they
yeah they brought their family out but
nobody home we're gonna scream in the
parking lot together
that's good i like it that's fun well
we've got a copy of the new book baby
steps millionaires for you because
that's the next thing that's going to
happen for you guys you're going to move
on and continue this journey and start
putting your 15 away into retirement and
uh boom get the house paid off you're
going to be baby steps millionaires
that's your next thing we're also going
to send you a copy of the total money
makeover so you can give that away and
be an encouragement to someone get
someone else started on their journey
okay
all right awesome thank you so much dave
thank you guys i'm proud of you well
done all right jesse and katie in fort
worth texas sixty thousand dollars paid
off in two and a half years making 50 to
105. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how that's done
i love it
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping always use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from sarah in
georgia we are paying off our student
loans and it'll take us another two
years to get that completed we'd like to
get a will in place since we have two
young children we spoke to several
lawyers and they each quoted over two
thousand dollars to get one lord we
don't have that much extra cash and want
to put money towards debt we also have
looked into online wills but have been
told by our cpa and others that this is
like throwing money away and it probably
won't hold up in court your cpa is an
idiot wow we don't expect family to
contest our wishes or fight over any
money we have two houses and have about
300 000 in investments should we
purchase an online will or save up for
an attorney to create one for us
uh you need a new cpa
because uh they don't know what they're
talking about in this and it scares me
that they don't know what they're
talking about on something else
uh or they're trying to sell you their
will i know i'm curious is there a
relationship here with the cpa and the
attorney yeah this is interesting back
here no don't spend two thousand dollars
on a well no i mean most attorneys will
do them for three to five hundred on a
basic thing and you can go to mama bear
legal forms for i don't know what is 100
bucks 129 or something yeah with the
full wheel kit and we have that
there's
the wills are organized online the good
ones like mama bear legal forms are done
state specific and if you follow the the
steps for the state that you live in yes
it will hold up in court
no you can't go down to staples and buy
a will packet off the shelf that works
in every state
that part your cpa would be right about
but what tells me is is that your
cpa does not know anything about online
wills a few years ago i didn't either
but uh we've gotten to be knowledgeable
about them because i had the same
discomfort but there are several
companies including mama bear legal
forms that do state specific that's what
you're always looking for because some
cause
wills probate law is state law
it is not federal law so it is specific
to your state for instance louisiana uh
a lot of their law is very french based
where a lot of the rest of the u.s is
english-based law uh california weird
because it's california who knows what
country that is yeah we don't even know
what country that is and so but the
different states have different laws
some states are similar to others and
some of them are just completely whacked
so you need specific to the state you
are occupying at the time of your death
what is your residence so if you change
states you need a new will
by the way mamabear legalforms.com come
on that's the one we use me and my wife
use it as a product benefit through
ramsay and it's literally we give it to
everybody here free as a benefit so we
wouldn't do that to our employees if we
didn't think it worked there you go good
point
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage aaron is here with her
daughter maddie hi erin how are you i'm
fantastic how are you better than i
deserve welcome where do you guys live
live in lee's summit missouri the kansas
city area yes awesome very cool welcome
to nashville how much debt have you paid
off paid off 40 000
all right how long did that take 24
months good job and your range of income
during that time 48 000 and ended at 56
000. cool very cool so what kind of debt
was this
uh one was a brand new suv and two
credit cards
wow okay very cool so what what caused
all this to happen two years ago what
was your revelation your lightning
strike moment well i had bought a new
house and i had gotten
some estimations on the cost of living
and unfortunately a couple months in i
was getting real numbers and it wasn't
matching up with what my estimations
were
hundreds of dollars actually over
what i was budgeting at the time
and
i
didn't think it was thinking fast yes
yes and i was panicking
and i was running out of savings i'd use
up almost all of my savings for the down
payment and
um there was a point where i had two
dollars left in my checking account and
i had almost no money left in my savings
and i was like how am i going to do
this how am i going to live how am i
going to support my daughter and just
keep the walls up
um
the rumor is maddie she likes to have
like a
heater that works and clothes and
food and stuff like that oh yeah these
teenage daughters they're hard to get
along with that way right oh yeah yeah
they like they like to eat regular and
yeah oh yeah okay yeah every once in a
while
what do you do for a living i'm a
healthcare interior designer okay
health care
interior
what the flip is that
um i help design hospitals oh
okay
that makes more sense all right like i
was somehow visualized healthcare at
home i don't know
a home interior designer but as soon as
i hear an interior designer my wallet
twitches so
uh the next time you're in the small one
it's my wife's favorite category but
yeah someone shows this couch right here
look at that all right there you go
something like that good okay cool so
you get in this fear mode
it's caving in on you yeah what'd you do
how did you find us
so the church i was attending at the
time was one of the host churches for
margin kansas city yeah and
i'd like to say i signed up at the time
but i couldn't convince myself that i
could afford a hundred dollars to take
class and i
it was just something that god put on my
heart if you'd asked them they'd
probably given it to you probably yeah i
wasn't wise enough at the time
so
um i just kept wrestling with it and
wrestling with it and i finally know i
have to do this because i i have no
other options i i have to make a
decision now
and so that's when i decided okay well
i'm still going to do fpu it's just
going to have to be independent and i
started on september 1st 2019
and just stuck with it for the next 24
months and
i made some mistakes in there brought a
brand new suv because i had a um
another vehicle that was so you really
didn't go through the class how do you
mean you just started doing like you
started watching youtube videos or what
are you saying so i brought the ramsey
plus membership and got all the tools
and the book when you can watch fpu and
that that's how it works right yeah okay
so so yeah i just got my hands on
anything i could just just listen to
everything and um
i just
you know i
i really
just kept with it because 20 out of the
24 months
i had major financial things that came
up
and some planned for most not planned
for
i had a knee surgery had a dog attack
emergency vet bills my car was
vandalized my kitchen flooded
absolutely everything was coming in and
it's like you know i'm i can't give up i
can't give up and um
you're a fighter so september 8th of
2021 um
i finally got some checks from a life
insurance
policy that i decided to cash out to
help
end my debt payoff process and get me
into uh baby step three finished it and
it did and it was two and a half months
of fighting with the life insurance
company to try to get it closed out and
i was just i was just weary i was i was
so exhausted
um and that's really really where my
cheerleaders came in and
really encouraged me at the end who were
your cheerleaders
so um
family
mom dad step dad um my good friend
ashley here um my daughter and my
financial advisor because in the middle
of all that when they made the mistake
of buying a brand new car one i
shouldn't have um i realized i i need
someone to speak specifically to my
situation and so that's when i hired um
a ramsey financial coach
and he helped me make better decisions
very good good very good cool
cool well you've done it
so after the weird thing is is that when
you finally get the other side of the
debt and you finally get control of your
money it's funny to me how the
emergencies leave
right it gets real calm yeah um scary
almost calm yeah it wasn't wasn't as
intense with the emergencies that came
up i still had some that that came in
but i was able to pay cash for it
and that was the big difference because
i cut up the credit cards and i've never
been in a position where i felt like i
needed to
get a line of credit or use a credit
card after after i got those baby steps
down i got the emergency fund and knew
where every single dollar was going but
it truly is murphy's law that when
you're broke and i remember that first
sharing of me when you're broke your
life looks like a country song i mean
the knee goes out the dog gets bit i
mean it's like a chorus in a song it's
ridiculous yeah and it's like how do you
make this stuff up you can't make it up
i mean it's like only the devil is this
creative i mean it's unbelievable so
yeah it's uh but then when you get the
other side of it you look back and you
go well look at there right it's just
kind of like the the storm clouds part
and it gets a little calm and the sun
comes out oh you know i mean it really
does happen that way it's really strange
i'm proud of you you're a scrapper girl
resilient
you are a scrapper
and i'm sure maddie's been watching you
she's got a good model now and how to be
a how to be a warrior woman
you're awesome it's good stuff that's
good stuff it's good to have a a mom
that you can look up to that's like that
very very cool good stuff
all right so uh what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is now
that you've actually done it commitment
you have to
you have to know
um
what your plan is and keep that in front
of you um i had uh the scripture um
up on my refrigerator so that way i was
looking at every single day this is what
helped keep me committed and writing
stuff
on my mirror in the morning to remind me
of where i was at who i was as a woman
and where my path was going
and
just know that
challenges are going to come up and you
have to decide is it going to get you
down or are you going to you know dig in
and keep going um so you have to be
committed yeah wow was it a specific
scripture that you had up yes the poor
are always ruled over by the rich so do
not borrow and put yourself under their
power which is proverbs 22 7. yeah it's
good stuff that sounds like contemporary
english version yeah i like it i like
conversion that's good
that's the old rich rules over the poor
of the borrower's slave to the lender is
the old king james yeah way to go that's
good i like it
boom
kick it yeah done well done all right we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next thing on your
list for sure go on and be a millionaire
now yeah and uh then you can really
really really be in charge this is
awesome well done and a copy of total
money makeover you can give it to
somebody that's starting their journey
stir them up cause a holy ruckus that's
what we're here for well done all right
aaron and maddie from lee's summit
forty thousand dollars paid off in 24
months making 48-56
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
well done
man i love stories like that it's
wonderful pastor randy frazee and our
buddy up there in kansas city got the
whole
city yes 30 or 40 churches to go through
financial fish university at one time
and they called it margin that was the
campaign i went up and spoke for him and
went up and spoke to the group of
pastors it was an incredible incredible
time incredible movement he'll be proud
to hear that he had a little part of
that story
very very well done
good job aaron you're a rock star
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones as we talk
about your life and your money here on
the ramsey show stephen is with us in
san diego hi stephen welcome to the
ramsey show what's up hey dave hey hey
babe
good thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help well
i'm looking at paying off my house
um in the next few months
but i wanted to ask you if i'm
in the financial situation
if my money situation is where it should
be in order for me to do that okay
what's left on the mortgage
about 95 000
all right and how much do you have in in
liquid cash right now
about a hundred and thirty-five thousand
okay and what's holding you back from
paying it off
i don't know
is it just emotional do you have other
debt yeah
no no i've never owned a credit card in
my whole life what would a three uh
three to six months emergency fund look
like for you
well that that was kind of my question
because once the house is paid off i
imagine my my six month emergency fund
would go down slightly because i don't
owe
anything on the house agreed sure
so if you paid off the house today you'd
still have 40 grand sitting there as an
emergency fund which would i'm guessing
is good for you
yeah i mean according to my wife that's
not quite what she wants she would like
to have a little more but when i look at
it you know just
from a money standpoint from a numbers
standpoint it makes sense what's your
household income
um
about 125.
okay
well i wouldn't disagree with your wife
um
if you wanted to have a little bit more
that's not a problem for me
but what i would do is say this let's
pay off the house today and our first
goal is to raise it from forty thousand
to fifty thousand
that's that's what that was my thinking
yeah you also don't have a payment in
the world it back up pretty quick it
sounds like the security gland there is
flaring up for her but when you don't
have a mortgage payment man it's going
to open you up to a lot of options and
very little stress
yes
yes very man our original plan was to
have it paid off by april which would be
my 40th birthday which i was excited
about but
when when i sat down and started looking
at the numbers i was like we can we can
do this a little sooner if we really
wanted to tonight and uh
i wasn't kidding
and then you can plan a celebration trip
on your 40th birthday instead of having
to go to the bank yeah tonight and then
let's just scratch and claw and get her
done man i mean uh
knock this out uh you know build up that
emergency fund a little bit more
and then say okay now what's our next
trip what's the next thing we're going
to do yeah well we've already the funny
thing is we've been planning this for so
long we've already spent so much money
and the house isn't even paid off yet
because we're finding all these trips
and all these ideas that we want to do
once the house is done we've been you
know sacrificing for so long and
we're right there yeah it's time
it's time and of course you can tell her
the same thing i always tell everybody
if you hate being out of debt you can go
get you a mortgage
[Laughter]
yeah you know that's not gonna happen
yeah i way to go you've done saved up
all this money for what let's pay off
the house i feel like george we're the
two guys on the bungee jumping off the
side of the bridge and we just tie
people to the bungee and they stand up
there and look at us till we push them
yep
do it go
right now
i'm scared of heights dave so i'll let
you be that guy oh no we you're we're
not jumping we're pushing oh yeah i like
that plan a lot better
we've already done our jump we're both
debt-free man way to go stephen that's
awesome well done sir emily is with us
in portland maine hi emily welcome to
the ramsay chef
hi thanks so much it's great to talk to
you i've been listening for about six
months so i'm new
um
i have a question i about money in
canada i lived in canada for nine years
and i'm recently back in the us
um
canada allows you to
catch up
in retirement if you didn't put enough
money in in the past
and so i'm trying to decide whether
to
put catch up i i didn't do a very good
job uh with retirement up till now
catch up some of
what i didn't put in in the past
first is so in my canadian retirement
versus
bringing all of that money into the us
and to put toward a house my first house
um
are you you're going to stay in the u.s
i'm staying in the u.s now yes
all right
yeah i'm going to do everything in the
u.s so i'm just going to move everything
here
and manage your retirement accounts here
and manage your house here and so forth
if that's where you're going to be
because it's going to be hard to
manipulate a retirement system in a
country you don't live in anymore
right it's going to be a process and and
it's harder to keep up with what's going
on with it and so on so yeah i'm going
to use that how old are you
i'm 51. okay do you have other
retirement money
yeah so i have um the equivalent of
about
100 thousand already in canada um and
then about
sixty thousand in the us i'm just
starting again in the us okay
but if we get you in that house if we
get you in that house then you can start
on your us and get a little bit more
jacked up about it right
okay yeah i have about a hundred
thousand saved in the us for a house so
far oh wow okay so i'll give you a
couple hundred there a couple hundred
buy pretty good house in portland won't
it
yeah yeah pretty good uh although
portland's pretty expensive it is yeah
maine in general is expensive but
portland's a it's a wonderful town i
love it it is it is i love it too
yeah really hard to stay away from it's
pretty much a postcard every time you
turn the corner
right yes it's a good way to put it yeah
beautiful beautiful well hey
congratulations a good job that's fun
interesting i never thought about the
canadian retirement and i don't know the
stipulations when it comes to retirement
converting that to u.s dollars
i don't either but that looks to be
honest with you and i guess the
conversion rate would play into it but
it's just kind of where you're going to
make your home you know we don't buy
rental properties in another state we
buy them in our neighborhood you know
where you're going to make your nest
make your nest it's kind of that's more
of the philosophy rather than the
technical details that were driving my
answer there yeah to move but i like the
idea of her getting the house getting
that thing paid off and then really
jacking up the retirement for you know
10 years makes a lot of sense
jacob is with us in saint louis hi jacob
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
my dad had a stroke back in august of
last year and
my mother relies on his pension
and
with
with his mental status right now she's
pretty much a full-time caretaker
and
he's becoming really hard to deal with
and so i'm trying to think of what's the
best situation to do
um and i've i've been kicking around
ideas of you know she could go to
or she could send him to a nursing home
and she could come live with us because
she's got debt
and what her fear is that if he goes to
the nursing home she's going to lose
everything because she can't afford it
and the nursing home is going to take
all the money
and so i mean it would take us a little
bit of money but we could
we could uh add on to our house
and she could stay with us for a time
being and she could get a job i'm also
worried about her well-being
and
i'm just trying to think of the best the
best route to go
how old are they
uh my dad is 65 my mom's 55.
okay
all right
and they don't have any any savings at
all
okay so the only thing that she would
lose would be her home and she's not
going to lose that here's the thing
nursing homes you know they're a simple
transaction
they don't take things you choose to buy
their services or not buy their services
and you pay them for their services
it's like you if you don't want to go if
you don't want to the restaurant to take
something for from you don't go over
there and eat
you know so they're not they don't have
a gun they're not you know they're not
forcing you coercing you in any way if
your uh dad and mom are uh meet the
medicaid guidelines for the poor
welfare nursing home is basically
available which is government-funded
nursing home in other words
uh and they they have guidelines for
that that allow the spouse to keep the
house keep the primary residence and up
to a certain amount of cash so if they
don't have much cash and she wants to
hold on to the house that's probably
doable for him to be on medicaid nursing
home
but you have to prove
like you do with anything with welfare
what your asset base is and what your
income is to work with
and i don't know with his pension if
he's going to qualify for medicaid or
not that's what you have to look into so
i guess you've got to just continue
gathering information and exploring your
options out there
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
you jump in we'll talk about your life
your money your work your relationships
it's what we do here at ramsey
solutions thanks for joining us
chris is with us to start off this hour
in new york city hi chris welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave how you doing great man what's
up
oh i got a great scenario for you
um
well i'm a i'm a full-time single father
i work full-time as a truck driver
um
my schedule is very tight
with my daughter's mother we split
custody
i have residential
um
i work about a 40 to 50 hour work week
and
to get those extra 10 hours to have her
help out and watch our daughter
so i get a little bit of overtime is uh
near impossible most days
um i want to buy a house
i live in a one bedroom apartment right
now with me and my daughter she's two
her bed is next to mine
and i want to give her a better life
i um
i've been listening to you for a while i
i have an emergency fund i um
i started a mutual fund a roth i.r.a i
have a pension through my job a great
union job
but i want to leave new york
because i don't think
new york is a great place
for um
to raise my child but i don't want to i
i don't want to rip her away from her
mom but
it is i
i don't know what to do
i thought i couldn't uh get advice
so
how many hours a week do you have the
two-year-old
um pretty much whenever i'm not at work
which is uh
i get all work at five
um
i pick her up at five thirty and i don't
know where your ex-wife has the baby
during the day
yes she works the night i work during
the day
[Music]
i um
i i i i like i said i have a great union
job but i don't see myself living
comfortably in new york
um
as you you know i'm sure you're well
aware this place is uh turning into a
communist regime and uh
i i don't see much
like future
outside of this company you know in this
company
um
you know trying to like buy a house i
think it's a struggle what are the
parameters for how far you could live
[Music]
i'm sorry what was that what are the
parameters for how far away you could
live
she uh
she's um
as in leaving like the state right well
if you were let's say you're in new
jersey or you were you know on one of
the islands there what's the
ramifications of that as far as
transportation and and getting your
daughter to
to her mom
well
we we both live uh in suffolk county
further east and long island um she
lives about 20 minutes away from me her
mom is uh has no license
no car
uh i'm driving back and forth every day
to drop her off and take her off
trying to make the best out of a bad
situation you know
yeah
well i mean you're in a tough spot i
don't know that you know buying a house
is going to happen in the next few years
for you but it's definitely attainable
in the long term do you have any money
saved up right now
i have an emergency fund i have about 12
11 grand in the bank about um
the whole the only way i would be able
to buy a house and i know you're
probably going to be 100 against this is
uh going through
like that put new york has a uh two
percent rule or three percent rule where
you can put like three percent down
and uh go through like all these
programs um my my company offers a uh i
think to help
pay like uh 25
uh grand off the uh the price of the
house
but there's stipulations
yeah there's all these you know there's
always strings attached nothing's free
yeah i don't like that part
yeah
that's the only way i'd be able to buy
something and
that's the only way you'll be able to
buy something today
yeah yeah
so okay there's a couple of decisions
you've got to make you're going to have
to line these things up you've got a
series of things that are all good
things
but some of them are not as high on the
list of good as others
okay
good thing okay good thing you're able
to share parenting
with your ex
and uh that's good for the child it's
good for your all schedules
that's a good thing
good thing you're in your baby's life
and you're there all the time
big time good thing right
good thing yeah you've got a good job
uh that you don't dislike
bad thing you don't like the political
climate
bad thing the schedule you keep is
wicked hard
bad thing
property's expensive in your area
you following me here
and sometimes sometimes if i just write
those things out the way that i just
laid them out there i start going okay
what is the most important thing and i
may not be able to get is some of those
bad things so bad that i've got to give
up a good thing
an example would be
you decide i'm not suggesting that this
is true i'm saying an example would be
metaphorically
that you decide that the political
climate there is just absolutely
untenable i don't want to live here and
i don't want to have my child here
then even if that means changing jobs
even if that means being away from the
child's mom you're out of there
if that's the bad that's the top thing
on the list
but if that thing can has to be
tolerated in order to get some of the
other good things and it's further down
the list then you can do it so when you
kind of make this list and you go okay
what is the most important thing on this
list bad or good
that's going to force me to make this
decision
because you're going to eat something
here you got too many things going on
that are
hard
and something here is just going to be
hard
meaning you're going to move away and
that's going to be hard or you're going
to stay
and that's going to be hard for a
different reason so uh what you're gonna
have to do is prioritize your decision
making out like that and then once you
decide like for instance if you decide
okay
i'm gonna put up with this crap and i'm
gonna roll my eyes and we're staying
because it's so important that i'm near
the ex for the sake of the baby
let's just say that that's your number
one thing
then that means you're going to put up
with the political crap
and that means you're going to put up
with this wicked weird schedule
and that means now in that environment i
say start saving for a house and it
takes me three years four years
i don't care but we got a plan now given
the constraints
but otherwise the constraints all just
feel like chaos yeah and it steals the
hope from the future yeah he needs a
five-year plan here and she's going to
grow up she's going to go to school the
situation is going to change your income
is going to go up so have a long-term
mindset and uh know that this isn't
forever yeah i was wishing you were
going to tell me the kid was 17. that
would have been nice so there'd be a
little more light at the end of the
tunnel but this is an 18-year or a
16-year proposition we're looking at
here
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me 130 000 all
thanks to what i learned at bethel tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
well it's book launch week for the book
baby steps millionaires it is on the
street and it is in the wild and it is
selling like crazy thank you guys we
appreciate your support
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too
to complement the book launch and to
continue the message that it is
possible to be financially successful in
america today don't let those hope
stealers out there knock you out don't
believe what they've got to say they're
wrong
some of them intend to be wrong and lie
some of them are just ignorant
but they're wrong don't let the hope
stealer steal your hope it can be done
we're going to prove that to you without
you being desperate
and greedy and out of control with crazy
crazy investing
we're going to talk about building
wealth 2022 tomorrow night thursday
night at 7 00 p.m central time george
campbell to my right rachel cruz and i
are going to discuss how to build wealth
in this climate in this current year
what's working what's not what's shiny
what glitters what has a confetti cannon
what's boring and works every time we're
going to cover every bit of it and it is
a uh the event is completely sold out
the 1500 1600 tickets in room sold out
in just minutes days whatever very very
quickly
and uh we currently are over 120 000
people signed up for the live stream is
that a record that's uh no it's getting
close though wow getting close reset
last year was about that size that we
did
and uh but yeah it's we'd love to have
you you can watch it on the live stream
free
all you got to do is go to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth and you can register for the free
live stream did i mention it's free
we're going to take a couple of hours on
uh
uh uh
whatever day that is thursday night the
13th tomorrow night i hope i can still
talk to you launch a book this week
what's going on i'll talk by then my
eyes are crossing but yeah check it out
don't miss it ramseysolutions.com
wealth we're glad you're here beth is
with us in houston texas hey beth
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave
hey what's up
hey hey i have a wonderfully awesome
problem
okay i like those
yeah yeah okay so just a little
foundation our house has paid off we
have saved for retirement
we have savings to get to for an
emergency we have no debt and we have
three kids that we have 529s for
the oldest one is 20 21 the second one
is 20 years old and then the baby is 18
years old so i have two in college and
one that's a senior
and the two in college we have managed
to cash flow all their college education
so far because they had wonderful
scholarships and they we knew that they
were probably going to go on to
secondary graduate school um the oldest
one just got accepted to dental school
so in the fall she'll be doing that
thank you you guys are killing
yeah
but so now what's happened though my
wonderful problem is are my in-laws i
gave the kids money
for for them but they they gave them ten
thousand dollars each
and our kids being responsible you know
they are going to listen to us for what
we say we should do with this money and
of course we want to save it for their
education so
more so i thought education was covered
well
it what we have saved probably won't get
the oldest two through
like that's not going to get them
through dental school the oldest one
wants to go to dental school she's been
accepted the second one wants to go to
medical school she's got a 4-0 in
college so i bet she will be able to go
yeah and so that we have about 66 000
and 529 per kid
yeah and that's not going to get them
through four years of dental and medical
school yeah just drop it in the for drop
it in the 529. it's only 10 grand he
thinks
yeah you think just dump it all in all
at once stagger it in or should we just
just drop it in there just drop it in
there you're going to be using it
shortly it's not going to be in there
that long
well that's what i thought it should
instead of putting it in there and then
pulling it right out should that first
semester for the oldest child just write
it out the checking account it's fine if
you want to do that it's nothing bro no
problem either way it is gr whatever
growth it gets if it's however long it's
in there is going to be tax free if you
drop it in the 529 that's the only
benefit but it's not going to grow that
much if it doubled it'd only be ten
thousand dollars
yeah so it's not you know if you just
use it for that first semester that's
fine too
but yeah definitely lay it on the
education label without a doubt because
you got a lot of education bills still
coming
and um so if you want to run it through
the 529 and let it sit there a little
while use some of the 529 money that's
been in there a while that's fine but
it's six and one half dozen others it's
still going to work out about the same
there's not a long timeline here so it's
not like it's going to have 10 years to
grow so like dave's saying right
i'd be making a plan to try to cash flow
dental school medical school all of that
considering you guys are debt-free
you've got some sharp kids that aren't
afraid to work aren't afraid to get
scholarships so it can be done and i
can't wait to hear you call us back and
say we sent all three kids debt-free
medical school dental school it can be
done wow that'll be cool
that's a bill right there
yeah we're biting it off here man this
is big this is big but yeah that i think
you may just you go ahead and use it
just dump it in the checking account
like you said use it use this 10 000 for
the next next check that comes up and
then just keep rocking but george is
right pan back and let's get together a
full plan you all have done such a great
job beth
getting to this point
uh i would hate to look up and each one
of them have 400 thousand dollars in
medical school and dental school debt
at the end of the story after you got
this far and did a great job so
be very aware that all medical schools
are not equal
in quality nor in cost
and there's not necessarily correlated
same thing with dental schools and
honestly some of the dental schools are
absolutely insane
you should never go there based on what
they cost i just thought of the barred
future documentary with our our buddy
who took out a million dollars he's got
a million dollars in debt and he's an
orthodontist orthodontist yep that's the
thing man
so wow wow wow
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five kylie is with us
in houston texas hey kylie how are you
i'm good hi jay nice to talk to you you
too what's up
so my my husband and i are under
contract for a house so we close on in
two weeks and he got a job offer in
colorado
that we are really considering taking
but we're under contract and we don't
know if we should just
walk away from the house and lose the
money we put into it so far which isn't
that much or if we should because we
won't be moving out there till the
summer anyway so i don't know if we
should stay and then try and resell the
house
because that's what you know a lot of
people are telling us to do with the
market
but it seems like a lot of work to me
and like a risk i'm just not sure what
to do it's a lot of work and it's a risk
but you have your you've given your word
what do you mean
i mean you promised these people on
paper you were going to buy their house
okay well our realtor said we could walk
away don't give a crap what your realtor
said
okay well that's fine i mean
you do what you want to do but if i if i
told these people i was gonna buy their
house i'd buy their house
i want the house
i mean well you're not staying there
you're not staying there if you're going
to colorado but my point is is that you
have a moral obligation to honor a
contract that you signed giving your
word to buy a house
it's not those poor people's fault that
you took a job afterwards
so you need to consider whether you take
that job as a part of that situation
but um
i think you should close on the house
because you said you would now then can
you resell it and make money i sure hope
so
if you're going to colorado and i would
actually put that in as a stipulation as
a part of taking the job with a new
employer that they buy your house that
you just bought yeah if you can't sell
it for a profit within x period of time
or maybe you're not supposed to take
this job but i can tell you this you're
not going to call this show and me tell
you to break your word
i'm curious about the decision-making
process if there was a job offer some
interviews happening here while the
house is happening house has been under
contract for a long time it closes in
two weeks
yeah and then the job offer came out of
nowhere some dub on linkedin called him
and he just got the hot foot
and uh so
no i mean you gave your word can you
keep your word
[Music]
that was old-fashioned
dude look at that old-fashioned
wow grandpa said you shook your hand and
you meant it i just like the word dupe i
think we need to bring that back yeah
well linkedin dude in particular
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions is
george's wife on the debt-free stage
george you're supposed to be out there
oh all right then well
you need to get moving all right i'll
get on the other side dave give me a
moment all right i'm gonna fill for
george while he
makes it out to the dead free stage um
he's torn between being a co-host and a
husband
and
[Laughter]
so
we'll get him trotting out there and uh
yeah pretty good hustle there george
that's good all right so george and
whitney are with us on the debt free
stage and uh somewhere around 700 or 800
ramsey solutions people george you're
costing me about fifteen thousand
dollars a minute here
i knew you were doing the math i don't
even know half of these people they're
just here to not work
hey you shouldn't say that about people
celebrating for you all
all joking and cutting up aside george
and whitney are here to do their debt
free scream the first ramsey personality
to ever do a debt free scream and uh
this one's really special how much did
you guys pay off we paid off a little
over 165 thousand dollars oh 165 000 and
how long did that take
about 26 months 26 months
and oh by the way what kind of debt was
that it was the
house house and everything
i'm looking at weird people we are weird
i mean that so literally
[Laughter]
you guys are incredible congratulations
well we have a rule with team members
obviously we're not going to ask your
income since both of you work here that
would be highly irregular and
uncomfortable but uh pretty cool stuff
george during the time you guys have
been by getting married meeting each
other buying a house you've both been
working here getting the debts paid off
and then buying a house and turn around
knocking it out tell the story yeah so
we met here uh you know back in 2015
when whitney started
and uh in 2018 we got married and we
started off our marriage debt-free
thanks to the principles here i had 40
000 in debt when i started back in 2013
as an intern and i came in just learning
this stuff going through fpu and decided
you know if i'm going to work here i
guess i should like do this stuff and
see if it actually works and so i got
out of debt in two years and in 2018
we got married and we just had some
weird goals you know being here around a
lot of weird people and so when it came
time to buy our first house we were
renting for a little bit we just had
this weird goal of let's see how much we
could put down for a house and then see
how quickly we could pay it off
and so that's kind of how the whole
thing started and we were really just
dreaming together saying what do we want
our life to look like do we want to work
till 65 do we want to have options do we
want to go on incredible trips and what
could we do without a mortgage payment
so that's really what started that
journey 26 months later the house is
paid for from the time you buy it that's
pretty freaking incredible
and uh whitney uh you guys are truly
opposites of track george loves the
spotlight
you detest it that's true
you and i were in a meeting earlier
today and you're like i'm not sure that
i'm excited about yeah
i'm here
you're here you're here now she she's uh
more of the eye candy so she deserves
the spotlight i got a face for radio i
try to sit next to you
good move well played well played well
played but whitney um now that you've
done all of this and you've been you
guys have both been here for a long time
you've been plugged into this whole
process
now that you're actually there how does
it feel
i feel like it's still
surreal we kind of became addicted to
paying off
the mortgage like each month we would
look at what is extra in our budget and
we would do a lot of no spend months
which i know that sounds miserable to
most people but it almost was like a fun
challenge of what are the things we need
to buy
and what can we
you know not do the things that we want
to do and that just helped like expedite
our goal and get
our mortgage knocked out faster but
y'all were a little bit too intense
actually yeah you said you don't need to
be gazelle intense and i was like no
we're and she was more intense than i
was i found an iphone note from 2018 the
month we got married and i already was
doing the math on how much we were going
to put down how quickly we were going to
pay it off and we had this wild he
nerded out yeah oh yeah completely
knocked it out that hurts he's the
numbers guy that's so cool that's good
my goal to pay it off in four years that
was our big hairy audacious goal we're
going to pay this thing off in four
years and whitney said nah that sucks we
could do it in three i took my breath
away oh
and then it gave me a challenge yeah
the throw down the gauntlet baby yeah so
and two years and two months later boom
just like that just like that so what's
the first big thing you're gonna do to
celebrate
well uh dave we talk about this on air
about how crappy my car is yeah so
upgrading the car uh is
that's true it's hurtful but it's true
no it's just true it's not a personal
thing it's just crappy yes so that's our
a1 and then we would love to pay cash
for our next house and upgrade into
something a little bigger as maybe we
have a family one day no announcement
sorry if that's uh you know what excited
there uh we do have a a dog so i am a
dog dad which that word alone makes john
delaney he's standing yeah he's just
shot in his head yeah don't say dog dad
but you have a dog but you you are you
you are one of those people because you
you know french bulldog people are all
that way so you you brought the dog for
the debt-free scream right he did it
wasn't my idea it was the entire team's
idea yeah
they said hey we'll dog sit we're happy
to do it right you got a whole bunch of
dogs here well let's get uh on the dog
my dog is here with us today
you know her name's suzanne sims she's
one of our board members
bulldog gosh so there she is
this is olive olive and olive sheds she
does she's a shedder all all frenchies
do
oh my gosh that's just way cute
i think this might be the first this is
the first this is the first dog no i
think we had a service dog one time
olives is not a service no she's special
but she's not a service dog yes oh the
only thing more high maintenance than
olive is me
i'll say that
so
it's fine that is great well uh since
you're talking about moving up i think
it is a good idea just to point out that
yeah you're a big time ramsey
personality both of you work here uh but
you're not making two million dollars a
year neither one of you yeah i hope you
do someday thank you
speak that over here and uh uh
the
the other thing
so your home is modest you're newlyweds
it's a town
yeah you just got married you bought a
town home do you want to tell what it's
worth or not you don't have sure yeah
it's uh it's worth about 480. okay all
right and it's paid off in 26 months and
you guys have been married
three years three years over three years
yeah okay so very very cool well it's
good that our ramsey personality is an
example of the things we talk about in
so many ways but it's not like a four
million dollar house and you know on the
beach or something like that this is a
it's a it's a modest good starter home
and like you said the next good big goal
save up same move up in that and before
you do that get out of that crappy car
yours yes and the big thing dave was the
the walk the talk this initiative we had
in 2021 with our whole team to have this
huge 25 million turnaround of debt paid
off dollars saved and so that just fired
us up seeing all of the stories around
this building of people that were paying
off debt leveling up in the baby steps
and it just reminded me of why we do
this and my passion for this and uh you
know whitney was a huge part of that too
just getting fired up about how much
faster can we do this can we do it
before walk the talk is over uh in 2021
and so we made it by the skin of our
teeth there you go well thank you guys
both for who you are as people thank you
for who you are as an example
as a ramsey personality and as a couple
here and both of you working on the team
uh are excellent excellent team members
and uh good friends and we're just so
proud of you you guys are just amazing
george has gone all the way from intern
through about six or seven different
positions over the years has worked his
way up uh learned this stuff inside and
out lived it and becomes a ramsey
personality
uh in the last 24 months and that's
moving him into a whole different realm
of things he's always been on stage not
always but for a lot a lot of the time
been on stage here's a host and other
things but now he's moved into this role
and is uh you're killing it there as
well so you guys are just a picture of
success we're so proud of you well thank
you for helping me meet my uh my wife
dave i couldn't have done it without you
yeah i had nothing to do with it except
payroll
but there you go but i think maybe my
family no did that was was whitney
involved i mean was uh uh uh was my
family involved in this whitney actually
no
you've hung out you've hung out with a
few of the family members
oh yeah good friends with daniel's
daniel's wife yeah so all right here we
go guys
it's whitney and george
house and everything 165 000 paid off in
26 months and olive count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
we're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
i love it
first french bulldog in a dead free
scream this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first peter 5 8 be
alert and of sober mind that your enemy
the devil prowls around like a roaring
lion looking for someone to devour
leave your character with god it is safe
there
men throw mud at it but it will never
stick long on a true believer it shall
soon come off and you shall be the more
glorious for men's slander charles
spurgeon said there you go it's a good
way to go that's strong i don't think
i've ever heard that quote before i have
heard there is no statues erected to
critics
i have heard um which then someone sent
me a statue of roger ebert
but the uh
uh i don't know who did a statue of
rodrick but they did and um
i've heard aristotle said there's only
one way to avoid criticism say nothing
do nothing and be nothing that's a favor
and the eleanor roosevelt quote is what
uh small minds talk about people
mediocre minds talk about events and uh
great minds talk about ideas or
something along those lines you got a
good memory i'm impressed it's like a
rolodex in there that's uh well i've
been doing these quotes of the day for
30 years they stick in your brain but
the good ones do anyway
george congratulations that was fun yeah
that was an out-of-body experience very
cool olive made her uh uh uh youtube
debut yes and kelly kelly's letting me
know do not think that you can have your
dog for your debt free scream that was a
special privilege for me because you're
a per ramsey personnel as a matter of
fact i saw deloney in the hall and told
him he couldn't bring his
[Music]
so um cause his dog's pretty seriously
ugly yeah
that's true well he he said that i mean
i'm just telling i'm just going with
what he said we got a designer dog so it
comes with cute yeah yeah it's got the
cuteness cuteness factor going on for
sure no doubt about it oh those
frenchies are great dogs yeah and they
got personality they do they got lots of
personality
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five kenny
is with us in south carolina hi kenny
what's up hey sir um
just started listening to your show
today uh while i was traveling and and
honestly i guess
with your new book coming out um you've
kind of been in the forefront of some
things the last few days i've had
friends in the past that have talked
about some of your philosophies and that
kind of thing but
with most things i thought it was
beginning to the point where i could be
debt-free i thought i had to have money
in order to do so
um my biggest question after listening
to you
and hear some of these very inspiring
stories including georgia's today uh
congratulations on your debt free
thanks as well sir
um but i want to get to that point
myself but our problem is we live
paycheck to paycheck and and we're
taking care of some um our elderly
parents and that type of thing
and and we don't have a lot of
disposable income at the end of the
month um as a matter of fact in some
months we
we do have to extend things out with
credit cards and that type of thing but
we want to get to that point all right
i'll tell you what george is going to
jump in and give you a plan before i
before i forget though i'm going to go
ahead and tell kelly we're going to put
you on hold and send you a copy of the
new book baby steps millionaire and a
copy of total money make over both
that's a one-two punch that'll get you
rolling brother but georgia give you a
line up here well kenny uh thank you so
much for for checking out the show and
and
giving us a call that's incredible that
you just were listening today and
decided to call in so tell me about your
situation what's your household income
and how much debt do you have
um
we
make gross about 75-80 000 a year
and right now we're probably
300 350 000 in debt does that include
your house or is that just consumer debt
uh that is house student loans and
vehicle and that type of thing okay well
let's separate the house for now let's
put that aside how much consumer debt do
you have outside of the house
um the student loans in the vehicle
probably
200 of that wow
okay and how much of that is vehicle
um 52 000. okay so 115 student loans
50 in a car or cars
and 150 on the house
right okay
all right and are you guys doing a
monthly budget right now
or is this new to you um
where
i know what my budget is my wife is her
fluctuates a bit because
like i say her um situation with her
mother you know we
were paying some bills for them to
supplement what they're not getting
based off social security and retirement
that type of thing
um they live with you
my mother does
but her mother does not
okay
are you guys covering your four walls
right now are you able to cover food
utility shelter transportation without
issues
uh yeah for the most part okay well at
that point you've got stable income and
you're stable on on those fronts and
you're making all of your payments on
your bills
yes sir okay
how much do you have cash right now in
liquid savings and everything
um
my savings we probably got
10 to 12 000 for the side okay
and uh how much do you love these cars i
mean could you sell these cars right now
and help speed up this process of paying
off some debt and get something cheaper
um possibly yes
okay
is it one car or two they're 50.
what's the expensive one
um
new truck
and it's how much it's purchased how
much
the debt on it's about 35 000 yeah all
right
okay
well
kenny you asked and so we're going to
tell you
all right number one thing is when you
guys sit down together you and your wife
together combine your efforts combine
your incomes and combine your messes
okay your messes are the debt the
household that you got to support
a little help for her mom and dad that
aren't there a little help for your mom
that is there or vice versa or whatever
it is whatever it's taking to cause
these things to happen but we are now
one we don't run two different things
you're not roommates you're husband and
wife we're gonna be on one
budget as a matter of fact we're gonna
go even further than send you those two
books i'm gonna go ahead and put you
into ramsey plus which signs you up for
financial peace university to go through
the class
and you and your wife can go through
that together you can either go to a
local church and go through it or you
can go online and watch the videos
either way or both for that matter so
i'm going to give you the full freaking
enchil enchilada truck
i think you're going to do it all but
here's what you're going to end up doing
it may take you a little while to get
there emotionally
but the two of you combining all of your
income and then giving every dollar a
name on purpose before the month begins
part of ramsey plus is the every dollar
budgeting software makes it very very
easy to do you don't need to be an
accountant you don't have to be any good
as software anything like that this is
going to make it like a like using a
yellow pad to lay out a budget in detail
but if you do it in detail and you do it
together you're going to feel like you
got a raise because there's a level of
waste in all the disorganization there
always is for all of us and you're not
an exception the second thing is you
shouldn't have a vehicle that is 50 of
your dad gum income especially when it's
in debt and especially when you've got
all these other households you're trying
to support and especially when you've
got this much student loan debt so i'm
sorry brother but that truck's gone it
was insanity when you bought it and
we're gonna get rid of it because i want
you to get your life back so you can
drive anything you want to drive in a
few years i'm not saying you never do
that in your life but i'm saying at this
stage of the game you're broke you can't
pay attention you call the national
radio show saying i can't even make
bills without going into credit card
debt every month and so i've got
something's got to change here and so
i'm you know we're about to
about to clean this mess up and it's
going to get radical and we're going to
be on beans and rice rice and beans
we're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless we're working there as
an extra job we're not going on vacation
we've got a dadgum mess to clean up here
and you just draw back your fist and you
punch a hole in this wall man that's
what you're going to do and we're going
to show you how to do that with great
intensity with your wife together and
i'm also going to say that the set of
parents that are living on social
security that aren't under your roof
we're probably going to put them on a
budget too because they need to get
their crap together so you don't have to
support them they need to live on what
they've got coming in if at all possible
i don't want to go hungry i'm not trying
to be mean but they're probably doing
the same kind of junk they may have a
drug car sitting in the driveway you're
paying a payment on indirectly screwing
around with this stuff so you got to
clean up clean up clean up clean up yeah
you sell this truck it's going to
kick-start this whole process and the
book and ramsay plus it'll lay all this
out for you but you're going to have a
starter emergency fund of a thousand
dollars so take all that out of savings
and the rest of the money you now have
is going to go towards those debts from
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate take 5 000 of the 10 000
and go buy you a 5 000 truck to drive
for right now do you get this mess
cleaned up no payments boom i just got
rid of 750 bucks a month i love it kenny
call us back when you're debt-free call
us back if you want more encouragement
yes
hey man we're here to help you brother
all kidding aside you can do this stuff
that's why i'm giving it all to you so
you can go get it done and you call us
back if you need help along the way
we'll be happy to help you
george congratulations thank you dave
fun times the debt-free screen thanks to
james ben and kelly in the booth i'm
dave ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus have a friend or a family member
that needs a daily dose of ramsay advice
in their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you